the LG picare AO Furniture is what you
didn't know you need it also you can't
tell me otherwise they took inspiration
from Cloud City not only is it a
functioning air purifier from the gurus
at LG but it can also act like a nice
little table or nightstand it even has
built-in wireless charging a Moonlight
in case you're afraid of the dark and
it's super quiet at a minimum of 21 DB
swapping out the filter is super easy as
well just click click boom and your set
and it comes in three colors yellow
white and red so you've got options and
enjoy a good night's rest with an extra
spot to put all of your important things
mhm so you don't forget them and of
course charge your phone and snooze away
KN when you're going to be breathing in
the cleanest air